i hate to ask this this is this is
stupid but it could be really cool
you have any of your
rhymes from your songs
that kind of sum up
this journey from
childhood
trauma beyond all measure to
positive creative inspiration
i've been battling with my demons i'm
cowardice when i see him i'm powerless i
can't beat him but deep down i feel like
i need him power is freedom you can lead
them but can't feed them smiling on my
face but i'm dying under the surface
what is my purpose i'm feeling worthless
tell me what worth is my flaws i happily
greet him imperfections i love him my
enemies i defeat him man i know
somebody's gonna relate to this of
keeping it real is a sin you better pray
for this because i wanted this [ __ ] all
my life till i finally got it and
realized there's so much more to life i
used to dream i'd become the [ __ ] man
i am stacking money and reading my son
sam i am love life can't tell you how
much a fan i am this is grown folk music
if you did not know 30-something i ain't
rapping by no dumb [ __ ] hoe keep it real
bobby boy he ain't no kid no mo now keep
it real bobby boy he ain't no kid no mo
and if you feeling how i'm feeling let a
[ __ ] know
metaphysical milkshakers it's me rayne
wilson and it is i reza aslan how you
doing rain
i'm doing well man i'm doing well i know
we've both been out and around traveling
across this great nation and across this
great beautiful round globe
um
how have your have your travels been
your vacations and whatnot good good
good we had fun we all went to portugal
for a couple of weeks everybody came
home with kovitz so that was good oh
jesus uh
yeah but i feel like i feel like it's
been a while since you and i have talked
what have you you haven't been doing
this on your own or anything have you
because that would be weird well as a
matter of fact um i couldn't wait for
you in your portuguese covid
so i went off and i recorded an episode
solo
how dare you yeah i know i know
but i'm really excited about this
episode i'm really excited for you to
hear it and for our audience to hear it
this is the craziest story is um
i
once participated in this online chess
tournament
uh celebrity chess tournament i took
second place by the way
and
um along the way one of the people that
i played uh
and beat was uh logic
the rapper the magic his name the rapper
yeah bobby hall is his name but he goes
by logic incredibly popular rapper he's
got four or five number one albums
um
he's got an incredible large loyal fan
base um
and we we we hung out a couple of times
we recorded some comedy bits together
played a little chess
um really super cool guy
and uh a while back he sent me his
memoir it's called this bright future
and i knew he'd had kind of a rough life
and but oh my god razza i
i couldn't believe his life story um
you know
from his dad
dealing drugs to teaching him how to
cook
you know
meth and crack to i mean ods and
um
just uh and
and uh
a mom who is uh completely uh bipolar
violent and um
anyways the list goes on and on but the
point of it is
bobby is such a nice guy and such a
sweet guy and he puts so much positivity
in the world all of a sudden i was like
i'm fascinated by this guy i am
fascinated this is yours bobby hall aka
logic how do you go through that
you know i've been in therapy for a long
time whining about my
you know the little injustices i
suffered in suburban seattle in the 70s
and 80s as a kid and then and then this
life story how do you go through that
and then give so much to the world in
his music his stuff is positive it's
uplifting he could go dark and he goes
light he builds community it's it's it's
it's incredible and um was really
excited to um
to have that conversation with him and
sorry i couldn't wait for you to get
back from portugal turning tragedy into
creativity let's hear this
welcome to metaphysical milkshake the
show where we go deep we get weird and
we search for the meaning of life along
the way presented by cass media and soul
pancake
[Music]
we uh
met
uh originally on an online chess game
yeah yeah you remember that so how how's
your chess going i play every day i
probably play
30 games a day three
you're probably better than me no i'm
not i play very badly
i just have fun i'm just like yeah come
on faster like i go through phases where
i'll play 30 times a day for like two or
three months and then i'm just like i
can't play chess anymore and i abolish
it from my life for months because i get
way too obsessed about it yeah it's
insane it's like the moment it's so
frustrating because i want to be better
and i've kind of hit this plateau and i
know if i want to be better i've got it
oh you've got lessons time study i've
got daniel openings yeah daniel ranch
from chess.com yeah yeah
shut up
one of the greatest sayings i've ever
heard about chess and it's how i feel
about life and creativity okay you can't
beat chess
it's a game you can't beat yeah unless
you're magnus carlson
basically and even him and he lose to
like a 17 year old from india the other
day or something like that yeah so it
happens
you have a tattoo of the goonies on your
arm
i do i have a lot of nerd [ __ ] all right
i never saw the goonies until a month
ago what what'd you think
i thought it sucked
i'm here to say unpopular opinion number
one the goonies is a terrible movie
everyone remembers the goonies as being
brilliant i am so sorry to say this it's
a bunch of screaming kids and they don't
stop screaming oh my god
and they're just like bumping into each
other and screaming and i'm just like
shut the [ __ ] up
you know what's funny about the goonies
it's like 20 minutes
like if you really look at the goonies
and like how how how everything happens
it's like the adventure of like getting
the treasure
it's like 20 minutes it's like they're
literally even though it's it's
when you think about it you know they're
out before the sun goes down and then
they're in the all night or i don't i
don't know whatever right yeah cause
it's like night and then it's the
morning and it's the whole thing
bro like just watch the events of just
the kids it's like they're on their
bikes
they get to the where the tour de
telly's whatever the hell their name is
they go underneath the thing and then
it's just they walk in one direction
like harry styles
and then they're there the rest of the
movie
is the cutaways
of what's happening
as the kids are walking so it seems like
it's longer but really it's almost like
a place takes place in different
dimensions of the story
nerd facts speaking of nerds i love
through the book you're always drawn to
the nerds oh yeah dude from the from the
get-go that's why i agreed to do this
interview
you were like that nerdy white guy i
want to hang with him with the coke
bottle glasses
why why why are you so drawn to the all
things nerd because it's me and i think
i've been so blessed to be that voice in
hip-hop
because like don't get me wrong i'm not
the first i think the first probably
openly nerd dude on a mainstream level
is lupe fiasco
but there's like a lot of cats
underground that were long before him
and me that were
you know inspired by all that i mean
look at wu-tang clan like kung fu
like you know like
anime but it's like amazing and then you
nerd it out on kill bill i love that
story yeah
discovered kill bill
through that the rizza because he did
the soundtrack through that discovered
wu-tang through that started rapping and
here i am and now it's like the riz is
my friend
like he just texts me and he's just like
hey yo bobby uso
he's like i hope you're doing good i'm
like yeah man [ __ ] this is wild that's
awesome no but that's how i feel about
you or [ __ ] jj abrams or like any of
my homies that i have i'm like how i
don't even know
what the [ __ ] but i think it's just
energy
you know real recognize real man like
all you guys are really cool you inspire
me
so i don't know what you like about me
but whatever it is i'm like all right
you know let's keep this circle jerk
going i like it
you do you know big boy from big boy's
neighborhood the radio personality yeah
he's like the godfather radio guy who
created the office greg daniels tried to
do a tv show with him well trying to
make him a star of a tv of his own tv
show oh man he's a he's a funny guy he's
a good actor he was in a couple couple
dopes i heard he was great films
and he um
you know on on my journey
to self-acceptance
which i've really kind of hit the peak
of
at the end of my 20s and they say you
kind of find yourself in your 20s and
you're kind of more comfortable in your
30s
he called me logic he was like logic
this this is a game
of enough entertainment is about enough
not cool enough black enough hip enough
hard enough rough enough rich enough
handsome enough he was like you're
enough
and i was like damn
that was knowledge man and when he told
me that i was like i am enough
so regardless of of people's
perception of
me
whether they think i'm too anxious to
this to that to whatever i just remember
i am enough and i and and also i cannot
please everyone
no
i can't and i wanted to and that's you
know when somebody comes at you and they
talk [ __ ] or whatever you're kind of
like oh man
why don't they like me bro cause not
everybody's gonna like you just accept
it i told this story on this podcast
before
one of our other
80 episodes
i don't remember which one but
when i first got into therapy
and was going through a real rough patch
this was maybe
18 years ago something like that
my therapist was having me say
affirmations daily affirmations
and he gave me like a printed list from
the internet of like
affirmations and the first one on the
list number one was i am enough well and
he handed me this sheet of paper and i
looked at it i just burst into tears
and that and i just read number one and
i was like
i can't i can't say that
he's like then that's the one you need
to say and he had me tape it to my
mirror
in my bathroom
and every morning i had to say i am
enough first thing in the morning and
even now like saying it like
that goes to such a deep wound in me of
like i am not enough and and maybe
that's something about creatives of like
that
you
you know it take to make a pearl you
know it's it's sand in an oyster that
forms into a pearl you know maybe it's
that that little that wound that that
that creates that and that if you are
satisfied that you're enough
it doesn't maybe it doesn't keep you
creative what do you think yeah it's
funny that you say that because it's
true it's like my whole life and
everything that i've gone through or
people telling me like you suck like
like it's literally like
you're never going to make it in rap and
then you put out a mixtape that's kind
of good it's like
you're never going to really get fans
and then you get fans it's like
well you're never going to get a record
deal and then you get a record deal
[Music]
you're never going to put out a major
album put on me i'm never gonna go on
tour you go on tour
all right you got lucky with the first
one your your second one's not gonna do
good second one does great you're never
all right whatever you're never you're
never gonna sell out the madison square
garden sell a massive core garden yeah
it's like you keep doing this thing and
i think it's that chip that kind of
helps that in a way sure but for how
long so that's my thing it's like well
how many number ones can you have how
many you know what i mean successful
tv shows films this that like it's life
is not about that it really isn't i mean
it's a part of it like having success is
great
it's awesome
it's an honor
but for how long bro it's like work on
you and now
like i can't tell you how i still
there's times i just feel like a fraud
i feel like i'm an imposter like for
real like i'm like i don't know how i
tricked everybody
but yeah
i did it no i'm just kidding
but yeah it's weird well let's go to the
very beginning why would you call
a book that is so
harrowing about uh one of the most
traumatic
childhoods
not only that i have ever heard of that
i could ever conceive of
why would you call this book this bright
future have you ever heard of manfred's
man ban manfred mansion yeah yeah so
they they used to cover a lot of bruce
springsteen yeah and they saw them back
in the 70s fantastic original music too
and i actually had to clear it with
manfred mann himself for
one of my last albums it was called no
pressure on this
album i have a song called heard him say
and the opening lyrics are sampled from
a manfred man
song called lies through the 80s
and there's a girl
and she sings
i saw a boy
walking with no smile on his face today
where is my place in this bright future
i heard him say and then i come in and i
rap and i go they say i ain't good
enough they say i ain't good enough even
if i signed yeezy i wouldn't be good
enough killing myself to make a killing
um it's whatever so like i go in through
this whole thing about
self-acceptance and it was something
about that song and writing that song i
was like
this is the title so that's why i
decided to do that oh that's that's
beautiful
let's cut to the chase this childhood of
yours is like
harrowing disturbing
um
by all rights you should be dead a
thousand times over or you should be a
drug addict
uh your mom obviously suffered from
bipolar
very severe
mental disease
uh addiction every addiction you can
possibly think of
crack and drugs alcohol cigarettes sex
you name it yeah um your dad completely
not there for you crack addict
you were conceived basically by two
crack addicts in a crack house
walking on a floor yep three days uh
crackhead ruthie's house
when you think back on that story
what are some key moments that pop out
from your childhood uh
the most
my mother being racist and using the
n-word on all her biracial children
that's a hard one to think about um the
time she almost strangled me to death
all the blood and my kitchen floor
roaches in the cereal boxes cooking
crack as a kid
um
holding my first gun at 11
throughout the book there's a handful of
photos uh that you post
living through this nightmare childhood
they're the only photos i have there's
like four yeah total from your childhood
one of the most undocumented childhoods
of all time yeah
which makes sense when you read these
stories
you're beaming in those pictures i never
thought about that you're just radiant
your smile is so huge
and time and time again is what got me
about the book all of this suffering all
of this trauma that you underwent the
beatings the humiliations the um the the
the
the the torture
that you underwent because it was really
just like
torture she did sleep deprivation you
made a joke about
something about sleep deprivation or i
never sleep or something like something
it was it was something about
i didn't even make a joke i just said at
some comment i'm like you know 11
whatever however old i am and i guess
there was this woman who had been
sexually assaulted and it was like on
the news
and some about sleep deprivation and i
think i said something like
i could stay up all night like i'm just
being a kid like talking out loud
thinking like not even realizing
like
what this news story is even really
about and then my mom goes oh you
[ __ ] think you could ah this happened
to me [ __ ] there's that voice
and then um
yeah she was like you're not going to
sleep tonight and she made me sit in a
wooden chair
um
and every time i started to nod off she
would scream at the top of her lungs
[ __ ] or
sir robert because my full name is sir
robert bryson hall ii
and she kept me up all night and she was
like i bet you'll never
whatever
you know again some
some uh mission she was on that really
didn't make any sense to me so yeah
in the midst of that you're smiling
these photos yeah and there's story
after story about ways that
you found
joy
yeah you found bliss in the midst of
this what were some of the things that
saved you
through that childhood skateboarding
yeah escape potentially rap eventually
rap video games i was always like three
consoles behind
and then uh i don't know why but it's i
was always like scheming i was always
doing something like this one time i uh
i went while i was home schooled and
when i say homeschooled i really mean my
mom slept all day because she was
drinking all night and then she would
show me hooked on phonics for like 20
minutes
and i'm like
12
and i was going through the rich white
people neighborhood
with uh
my
my homeschool credential that i
like had laminated and it's all [ __ ]
and i taped it on me yeah and then i'm
like
going up to people with a clear box
since
uh i said i was the poor people of
america fund
and would you like to donate a dollar or
more and then everyone was doing it so i
like up my ask yeah and i was like let's
make it five dollars
and then just like going to the ice
cream truck and just eating a bunch of
[ __ ] it's like the best memory ever
that's fantastic
honestly video games were such a huge
part in my teenage years because
some of my most um
like vivid memories are in a
um
3d space you know they're really in
these video games in these places
and in these video games i got to be the
hero man i got to solve like crazy
puzzles in
indigenous places in a game called
uncharted
you know i got to
save the day and and
in some weird way like here's the screen
that i'm looking at
and it just makes everything else
dissipate and i and i it does that to
this day actually except now it's
different it's like i'm not really
running now it's kind of like more of a
fun enhancement right there's something
else about video games that's
interesting that i think is relevant for
today's young people because i think
young people today
uh really struggle with um
[Music]
kind of grit and determination
and
it's easy for them to give up but they
play a lot of video games and the whole
point of video games is that you try and
try and try and then you die and then
you start again exactly you re calibrate
your strategy you come in well this time
i'm gonna take the sword or the gun and
i'm gonna go in this side door and i'm
gonna hit him on his knees instead of on
his shoulders or whatever and you try
again so there's a kind of like it
if you're able to take away a lesson
from video game
games it might be that kind of like
perseverance perseverance determination
i have this crazy crazy album
that i'm working on that i'll tell you
about after this and like when i wrote
the script for it because it's a radio
play like straight orson welles i was
like i'm just gonna write the craziest
[ __ ] i could possibly think of yeah and
then i got some big
some big boys on it to
act
which is so cool and then in between it
is like all this hip hop and different
stuff like that and so it's like i had
this idea of wow what could i do
creatively like what's the wildest
different thing and then once you know
what it is then you structure it okay
how long should this skip be this song
how many songs in a row and then you you
kind of you file it out i just released
an album called vinyl days and it's all
super boom bap hip hop fun stuff and i
discovered this woman that like nobody
knows about her name is nezzy mamadou
and i discovered her on tiktok and when
she was 15 years old her parents brought
her from nigeria
and um she then went to college and now
she works in finance and i'm just on
tick tock
and i just see this strong
beautiful black woman killing it like
and it's not like
especially when it comes to rap like
forget a dude or a woman or that just
her as a musician is like one of the
illest i've ever heard in my life and
nobody knows who she is so i was like
i'm gonna put her on my album
now
when i called her she was damn near in
tears and she was like i'm just a
regular schmeguler i work in finance i
can't believe you're calling me and blah
blah and i'm like hell yeah because
she's now in her 30s
still look good black don't crack looks
amazing
and she's still rapping like she
is the biggest rapper in the world
because she loves it and she's having
fun
and i think that's so important for
anybody watching or listening like
we're so brainwashed by not only social
media but entertainment and media in
general that everything has to be so big
so grandiose so number one so this when
it's just like dude if you gotta go work
a nine to five
and you love video games
at least you have something in your life
that you love and appreciate and if you
would love to be able to work on video
games for a living
figure it out yeah you can do it i mean
maybe you're not the guy you know with
the hundred million dollar budget at
playstation and but maybe not but
whatever you want to be into man comic
books um film cars
auctions fine art like you can be in
that world if you really care enough to
do it even if you're just making a
mixtape for friends like
when did that become like a dream how
does that work it had been a dream since
then like it just i was just like this
is amazing
and people were like
yo you're good at this and the more
i did the more things just happen i
don't know how to explain it you meet
other friends who like it like alan
watts said you start going to open mics
and performing and then there you meet a
producer and then that producer
you know uh sends you beats and then
after he sends you beats you put out
songs and somehow you run into a guy
from the radio station who gives you
more you know plays your plays your
stuff on the radio like some underground
college radio and you're like oh my god
this is crazy and then you meet somebody
who's knows somebody who's posting your
song on a blog and then more people it's
just like this organic thing
that happened but i really believe it
was the law of attraction energy like i
made it happen because i wanted it so
bad but i looked at it i always say with
you know persistence determination
realism and wanting success more than
your next breath i wasn't like [ __ ]
and hoes and boats and like i wasn't
like that's what it's going to be i was
like i can
turn this into a business and look
[ __ ] and boats is one of my favorite
songs yeah [ __ ] and nose and butts
did your traumatic experiences
from your childhood make you more
creative
for sure
yeah um i think
it gave me more detail knowing that life
can be that
traumatic
shows you so much more than just [ __ ]
and hoes and boats no it shows you so
much more than
just like two parents going to a job
putting you in a good school taking the
van
a nice little holiday
like it's like no you know it's just
getting raped and coming home and
understanding what sexual assault is at
six years old and police officers and
reports and your mom getting beat up and
like it's like those things where you're
like oh there's so much more here
you know so the other kids would just
look at life and look at family and look
at parents as like this is what it is
but i was like
i thought that's what it was watching
disney channel and all this and then i
realized oh no that isn't
all there is to life or relationships or
family and then so
by being forced to uh comprehend the
many sides of life and situations that
can arise in a household i was like well
wow there's
got to be many other sides and
situations to so many other aspects of
art so can you point to one specific
traumatic event that had a maximum
impact on your life as an artist
i mean there's so many in this book
there's hundreds it goes on and on and
on but then it's so refreshing because
all of a sudden you have the success and
it becomes from childhood or from like
the just the first one that comes to
like the the one that i think changed me
yeah whatever
so i think the thing that really changed
me is when i had the insane panic attack
in line to go see the star wars movie um
in 2015 and i was 25 years old and it
felt like an elephant was on my chest
and i'm like puking and like freaking
out and
i have to miss the star wars
uh movie to jump in a car
and i'm with my ex-wife and she drives
me to the hospital
and
i get in there i can't even sit down i'm
like freaking out and they get me into
bed and the doctor's like
you're having a panic attack and i'm
like what
no i'm not man i'm like i'm not man he's
like nah man panic attack
and i'm like what he's like you want
some ambien i'm like i don't do drugs
man oh no no no and he's like i think
she should take some ambien and i'm like
i don't think and he's like just take
some ambient and i'm like okay
and i take it then i'm like oh whoa
that was weird what's going on so how
did that influence your creativity
it [ __ ] me up so bad it scared me yeah
it it messed me up it changed my
mortality maybe yeah but also like then
i started experiencing this thing which
i still experience to this day but
through tools i know how to
it's not that deep derealization where
you feel disconnected from reality and
there's a glass wall between you and
everything
and like that scared me i thought i was
dying and i wrote a novel and that novel
supermarket is just literally me
being like going through my own
depression and
angst and all these things that were
going on in my life you know
romantically and personally and
professionally and all this i just
created this like
fake world that didn't exist based on a
world that that did especially me as you
know in my teens working at a
supermarket and all this stuff and so i
wrote the first half of this book at
literally just the height of the worst
anxiety i'd ever had in my entire life
and then i i worked on myself and i went
to therapy and i got these tools and
then i wrote the second half afterwards
when i was in a better place where the
character also eventually finds himself
so i think those are ways crazy events
in our lives can influence our
creativity so we're in a mental health
epidemic that is uh through the roof the
statistics around it are
absolutely staggering we've done a bunch
of episodes around mental health with dr
gabor mate and and many others um over
this last couple years of doing
metaphysical milkshake
but i love that title and we've um
but we've talked about
you know here just like anxiety like i
have uh a general anxiety disorder
sounds like you do as well oh yeah we've
been in therapy for like 18 years um
seems like you've been in therapy tell
me about your therapy
and
has your mental health struggles
helped your uh success and creativity as
an artist
yeah i mean well yes
without the question it's given me
something to write about
you know and even in like different
spaces like
i see there's this like monster that is
anxiety
and maybe he's a villain in a book you
know what i mean that i'm writing i mean
actually literally is that in my first
novel that i wrote but
um
yeah man i i
i love therapy
my therapist has
she's just given me such f amazing tools
like intrusive thoughts gnarly
describe that what's that well an
intrusive thought is
something that we all experience all the
time you could be standing in line and
you think about punching a cashier in
the face and you're like
where did that come from or like
something even crazier you know like
whatever your intrusive thought might be
and it's not really you
you're not sitting there going
like
i want to do this thing and i think
that's what actually makes us human
where if you have this
insane um
thought that pops into your head how you
react to it if you are like whoa
that shows that you are actually
human and i've i've learned that a lot
of our sub uh intrusive thoughts are
actually because we care about that
thing so much
you know so i don't know if you punch an
old person in the face
and you react you're like oh my god i
really love old people i would never do
that and then you it begins to bother
you because you're like why would i
think that but it's just like scumbag
brain you didn't think that it just
popped in your head
and then
next time say if you see a geriatric
person and you think it again because
you're scared that you're gonna think it
and then now every time you're seeing
senior citizens you're just thinking
about punching them in the face it's
like this like roller coaster and you
have to untrain you have to understand
most people don't realize that intrusive
thoughts about whatever it may be but
i'm just using this as an example the
last thing you want to do is freak out
and go why did i just think that because
it trains your brain like
to freak out like you're seeing a lion
or something when you're not
and it's like you could just be like hey
i see you intrusive thought
[ __ ] off
and and don't don't spend your time
worrying about it that's just like one
of the many things that has made my life
so much better
so you'd recommend therapy therapeutic
process to the listeners yes
do you get any full-on panic attacks
anymore it's been a while
because of i use my tools what tools
knowing that you've been here before i
think the thing about anxiety is is it
feels different every single time right
so it feels like it's brand new like i'm
like oh my god i've never felt this or i
feel dizzy or you know whatever and so
that's one thing that
is really difficult and then having to
be on
you know what i mean i'm not saying that
i'm on now but i'm just in in certain
circumstances where it's like all you
want to do is lay down and rest because
you've been grinding and grinding and
grinding you know recording an album
writing a book going on tour doing press
doing this doing that doing and there's
like you have to learn how to put your
foot down
for yourself and listen to your body
which is important which is what i'm
about to be doing after this
i'm gonna sit on the couch sweet and
relax yeah i i went through a phase
where i had anxiety attacks about uh
talk shows
really so i was just getting big on the
office i'd done a bunch of talk shows
which is a pretty nerve-wracking
experience
and especially if you're like known as
like a comedy actor because
you're like you're the expectation is
that you're gonna tell these killer
funny stories and you're gonna nail it
and get big laughs and that it's gonna
be
repeatable and replayable on youtube and
whatnot
and so i felt all this this pressure
like you said pressure performed yeah
and besides that period where i had
anxiety attacks in my 20s early 20s i
would feel like while on a talk show
like i'm going to hyperventilate and i'm
going to pass out on national television
dude and i was
certain it was going to happen i would
literally be there with david letterman
or jay leno or whomever i'd be like
just like
breathing trying to like look beforehand
or like
live oh whoa with the band and the
audience and the whole thing and like
i was just
terrified my eyes would bug out of my
head i would i'd go into a sweat i just
sweat would start wow i love how human
that you're so human you know what i
mean like that's amazing a lot of people
like to act or pretend or not even just
talk about what you're talking about
right now yeah i feel you i think the
biggest tool is
rest like true rest
being off your phone and finding the
source
of your anxiety
and i think the biggest source of my
anxiety
is failure
so because i'm afraid to fail
i overcompensate and oven overwork
constantly
when i should be relaxing even with my
wife and i give my wife all my attention
well most of it because it's like
there's a part of my brain that thinks
of a new idea for an album or a script
idea or a comic book or so on and so
forth and it just never stops
so realizing that the source of my
anxiety is fear um has allowed me to
combat and kind of
just tell myself shut the [ __ ] up it's
funny you say fear of failure because i
wanted to talk to you about your book
this bright future
um which is just phenomenal you're
talking about this fear of failure and
there was a seminal moment i forget
which friend of yours it was was it josh
or was it mike that said you need to rap
you need to get away from skateboarding
because on skateboarding you don't
commit
and and in rap you do commit and i love
this idea of committing i hadn't thought
of it that way i'm not very athletic i
don't know if you could tell i'm not i'm
not i'm not an athlete and um but i and
i tried to learn skiing like in my 40s
and skiing is just like skateboarding in
the sense that in order for it to work
you have to commit to going down the
hill you've got to get some speed going
in or if you want to gain control over
your skis i'm terrible at that because
as soon as i commit i'm like oh [ __ ]
yeah i'm going too fast i'm going to
fall over and then when you tense up
then you do fall over
but with rap you were talking about when
you first started rapping
as as a teenager 16 17 years old
like you weren't afraid to fail when you
started right i mean
he was talking about your ability to to
just throw yourself in and try [ __ ] and
and and and write and
try genres
would you would you say that's true yeah
especially because there was nobody
there
to see me fall or fail or this or that
in this creative space
because i was really just having fun
with it if your biggest fear of your
biggest anxiety producer
is failing
why are you doing [ __ ] like writing a
novel
and writing a memoir and doing a rock
album you know what i mean you could
stick to what you do really well yeah
but then the craziest part is is like
the stuff i'm the most scared about is
always the most
successful in a way at least looking
back like uh you know
statistically like what specifically
like when i dropped my indie rock album
i felt like a horrible failure because
everyone was like this sucks and now
it's like a cult classic in my fan base
yeah so it's like in the moment even if
i had failed
it's like one of my most revered like
you can't get the vinyl anywhere you
know what i mean like it's sold out i
have been with a lot of creative people
over the years i've been with from
a-list movie stars to to playwrights
doing theater in new york to film
writers and directors and and whatnot
and like coming into that little
compound that you were at before when i
when i visited you like
it was just a
cauldron it was a volcano of creativity
it was incredible you had finished your
book you were playing me some tracks
from the you know the indie rock album
some new indie rock you were doing where
you're playing guitar of all things and
singing you know not rapping and then
we were doing some comedy sketches and
then you played me some stuff from the
experimental rap album and from the from
the kind of like
more pop rap album and um
it was just like i was just like holy
[ __ ] this is like this is so inspiring
it was just
it was just this
volcano of creative energy so
how do you transform that suffering
into meaning that suffering into
creativity
well first of all thank you for saying
what you just did about my space because
i really feel like that's like been my
goal it's like
i want everything about what's going on
in my zone to like be inspiring
selfishly to me first
so it's like if other people come in and
feel that energy that just makes me
really happy so thanks for saying that
um
when i was younger like 19 20 i would be
writing songs
and i'd be like it's okay
you're gonna get through this like
you're worth it
but like
[ __ ] the listener i was talking to
myself you know because nobody else was
there to like really tell me that
and so i'm like it's gonna be all right
you know you're not gonna sell crack
forever no i'm just kidding but it's
like you're gonna be i never actually
sold crack i did cook it anyway
so
your brother sold crack to your dad yeah
just for i know clarity's sake
okay so as i
you know was releasing more and more
music i remember in 2015
on my second album i did a fan tour uh
where i basically got a tour bus and
then went from los angeles to new york
city playing fans my album early
and
they started saying something that was
really crazy to me they were like yo
your music saved my life
and i'm like what because in my my head
once again anytime i'm on the record
talking about it's okay you can
persevere through this you can do it it
was really me talking to me
and to know that my
words were really hitting these people i
was like man i haven't even tried so
that's why i then went on to create the
song 1-800 so
when you talk about how how can that
trauma transfer it's like well that
trauma was on me
and then i was like it's okay bobby
basically without saying my name on the
record you'll be okay
but then the fans heard a voice telling
them
they're gonna be okay that was their
message and then i heard their voice
back to me saying you saved my life and
then i heard a voice in my head that was
like you haven't even tried
to save a life so what if you do a song
and i did that song and i never you know
nobody was like yo this song about
suicide bout to blow the club up like
nobody was thinking that you know
but lo and behold it it really did its
thing so it's it's that childhood and
those adolescent experiences
that led all the way up to a song like
that
i guess the reason i keep coming back to
this is like a you should be dead
and b you should be jaded
and c
you should be
feeling sorry for yourself
and d
you should be doing absolutely the
minimum to just be getting by so how
how do you take all of this suffering
and make it this just like fountain this
cornucopia of
of of creativity it's very it's really
it's fascinating and i'm just speaking
here just to be really honest like
i had a difficult childhood in my way
you know we were very poor
when i was young
i got my clothes from the salvation army
we drank powdered milk because they
couldn't afford real milk that's good
but i was
my my situation was nowhere near i mean
not even not one hundredth not one one
thousandth of what you went through so
i'm not comparing it in that way
but
i in some ways now i look back and i'm
grateful on the struggles that i had as
a kid because that gave me that fire it
gave me that determination but i was not
at a place where it's like i should be
dead you know there was no crack around
there was just parents who didn't hug
you know
and who were checked out yeah um
so
again you should be dead you should be
jaded you should be bitter you should be
doing the minimum you should be addicted
to like 27 different substances
so
what gives well i think you know i've
had a lot of people say what you just
said to me
and i don't feel as though you did just
discredit yourself by any means but
different different paths are different
paths you know it's like if kim
kardashian's crying because she lost a
hundred thousand dollar earring at the
bottom of the ocean
that's her pain
like that's that's all she knows like
you know like that's just a real thing
it's like you know we could be like oh
there's kids in third world countries
dying and it's like
hey man
like we all have what we go through
right and it's like um there's levels to
it
like yeah so you went through some real
[ __ ] you know maybe you had a difficult
relationship with your parents that
altered who you are as a human being and
allowed you to have to
do some serious work and through therapy
that maybe you're still dealing with
just as i personally am like
but we're just dealing with it in
different ways so i just kind of want to
say like anybody out there who might be
like well damn i never had you know
bob's upbringing or this is it's just
like it doesn't matter like your pain is
okay and your pain is enough
one thing
separate question but one of the things
i was really struck by is you had no
moral compass from anyone it was guns
and crack and abuse and violence and
anger all around you constantly but
there's all these stories of like
the kids boosting you into that kind of
classroom to steal that money and then
you saw this tarp jar of money sitting
on the desk and then you saw on the jar
the money was meant for a kid with
cancer and you were like hell no i'm not
taking this yeah jar even though you had
like you know all the dogs outside going
like get the [ __ ] money bobby i was
like no i'm straight and then other
times you're like driving around they're
like here
shoot this gun or hold this gun or we're
going on this run and you're like i
shouldn't be doing this this is not
right this doesn't feel right like you
had this kind of like moral compass even
though it was not demonstrated to you or
for you
whatsoever and and your friend josh
came was he white josh yeah josh is like
the whitest man alive
excuse me
he's a pretty white guy
whiter than
probably not whiter than you okay here
we go he was of the culture but
you know two-story house multiple
bedrooms parents with great careers
lily white suburbs like lots of love and
support and he just went off the rails
yeah right into the thug life and you
talk about him like
how
why do you think that is like i was just
reading these stories like this doesn't
make any sense everything that i have
been reading is like our moral
imperative comes from
uh from
nurture not nature but there seemed to
be some kind of like
heightened sense of right and wrong
inside of you even though no one was
demonstrating that
i personally
am not a religious guy so now on the
other side i believe
in something
and what i do believe
as far as
why
somebody like friends of mine may have
gone down one path
when actually being born in a better
position than i was
and me kind of
at least as far as
success and
attitude and outlook ended up as though
they should have um you know born into a
happy suburban family
i believe that when we're born there's
doors man
an infinite amount of doors i know that
sounds crazy this is just like what i
believe
there's an infinite amount of doors and
you open one door and there's an
infinite amount of more doors
so there's
all of these paths that are in front of
us that have been given to us and the
first first one is out of canal
all right not your mama
and that opens
all these doors and i think a lot of my
friends opened doors
and continued
to go down a wrong pathway through that
those doors and if this door opens up
hey man you want to come out back and
smoke weed and then you go out back and
smoke weed as you continue to open this
door you're like
dying of an overdose like in a dumpster
like you know what i mean i'm not saying
that's gonna happen to everybody but i'm
like it kind of
a new set of doors begin opening and
that's what i feel man i feel like i
just
i went down some bad doors
and turned around and went back through
and maybe what is it that you what is it
about you at age 11 making moral choices
when you don't have anyone showing you
anything having to do with ethics
whatsoever
what is that i don't understand that i
think that's just does that mean that
human beings have some kind of like
maybe divinely inspired moral imperative
to kind of like do the right thing this
is not something that's trained but
there's something in our wiring
something in our genetics i don't know
what do you want me to say on the [ __ ]
man i made it no
i don't know man it's weird i wish i had
the answer and i think that's what i
struggled with with for so long like
this almost sense of like hood
survivor's guilt like why me why did i
make it out why is the rest of my family
[ __ ] up
it's like a hard thing to think about
like i could be some of my
family members
yikes like yeah
and i could be some of mine and believe
me
when we cut stop recording i'll tell you
some stories please so what is the
recipe for crack cocaine how do you make
it
i don't remember i just remember baking
soda being involved
a mason jar
i mean i was like
i don't know
i was young i was a
teenager did you wear like one of those
breaking bad like
no i was like no i was like just
inhaling all this [ __ ] and the craziest
part is that like the little girls
bedrooms were upstairs and this [ __ ] is
just going into the vents and it's like
you have pure cocaine that you pour into
this mason jar and then you watch it
i don't know
that's as close as i got yeah one of the
store repeated stories through your book
was the way that religion
and the 12 steps of aaa were kind of
used
as torture devices
to
uh
to traumatize you
like whenever you would do something
remotely bad or not even like you would
get lectured about the bible your your
mom's kind of bipolarness about being
she was literally either the virgin or
the [ __ ] yeah you know what i mean it's
wild um
but
how does that affect your relationship
to spirituality to have kind of like the
bible was used as a as a weapon
of of shame and humiliation and pain and
even aaa which is supposed to be like
this
open place that you know people get
support and love for one another and
support each other through their
addiction and their bad times your mom
would use it to like
hook up with people or score drugs or
try to you know
get money from folks and so these two
kind of like beautiful things when you
think about the beautiful holy words of
the bible and you think about the
beautiful holy words of a.a they were
used to just
squash you down yeah but i think it's
like when you're a kid
that's all you know it as so all i knew
it as was like this thing these things
that just sucked
and then you grow and you get older and
you realize oh no these are actually
amazing things they were just used in
the wrong way
you know but you're able to
differentiate
and once there's a lot of people that
suffered at all from the bible or church
or
uh religious hypocrisy yeah they're like
[ __ ] that i'm not having anything to do
with that
um but you you were literally tortured
by bibles
tortured by bible yeah i think and
you're still
you still have a kind of like a a
serenity about your connection this is
just one of those things i can't explain
it it's just so weird i just i don't
know you're right i should be like screw
this that should be like a satanist and
like you know just like oh yeah mom's
christian
but it was like i don't know i know i i
wish i could really explain it it's just
so difficult i don't know what it is i
think i just really
respect people man i respect people's
religions their beliefs their this or
that even if i don't agree with it or if
i think it's batshit crazy
i will respect the hell out of it
because it's like i can't disprove it
you can't just prove what i believe it's
like we're all just floating on a rock
you know that's how i see it what i'm
gonna argue with you about what you
believe in
you know especially if you're morally
sound as a human being like it's like
what are we even arguing about it's like
it's like the internet
you know you could be on the same side
but it's like it's not what you did it's
how you said it canceled and it's just
like jeez bro like
this is insane yeah i hate to ask this
this is this is stupid but it could be
really cool
you have any of your
rhymes from your songs
that kind of sum up
this
journey from
childhood
trauma beyond all measure to
positive creative inspiration
this is the whole i'm just gonna [ __ ]
read it
i saw a kid with no smile on his face
today where is my place in this bright
future i heard him say they say i ain't
good enough say i ain't good enough even
if i signed a yeezy i wouldn't be good
enough killing myself to make a killing
[ __ ] the [ __ ] i'ma just write what
i'm feeling
i heard him say i'd rather be hated for
who i am than love for who i'm not give
a [ __ ] if it's hot i saw a kid with no
smile on his face today where is my
bright place in this bright future i
heard him say
that boy different don't [ __ ] with him
but i'd rather stand out and stand in
let the story begin uh look in the
mirror and what i tell him reflecting on
my life from keanu and parabellum
i came a long way from where you was up
and comer with the buzz overcame selling
drugs overcame depression even overcame
addiction and had the courage to say
what others wouldn't with conviction i'm
always in the kitchen never my hopey
bitchin i saw a kid with no smile on his
face today where is my place in this
bright future i heard him say i am that
kid never mind who be bitching this is
for the person in the back who always
going to listen [ __ ] a punchline this is
food for thought like the lunch line we
all got problems the question is can you
solve them have the courage to face all
of them and resolve them [ __ ] i know i
can't cause i did it i know i can't
cause i've done it no matter what the
[ __ ] you're going through i'ma keep it a
hundred i know you can overcome it baby
mama tripping i know i've been there
boss caught you slipping i know i've
been there somebody beefing with you man
that [ __ ] ain't rare just keep it
pushing i saw a kid with no smile on his
face today where is my place in this
bright future i heard him say and this
is it i've been battling with my demons
i'm cowardice when i see him i'm
powerless i can't beat him but deep down
i feel like i need him power is freedom
you can lead them but can't feed them
smiling on my face but i'm dying under
the surface what is my purpose i'm
feeling worthless tell me what worth is
my flaws i happily greet him
imperfections i love him my enemies i
defeat them man i know somebody's going
to relate to this if keeping it real is
a sin you better pray for this because i
wanted this [ __ ] all my life till i
finally got it and realized there's so
much more to life i used to dream i'd
become the [ __ ] man i am stacking
money and reading my son sam i am love
life can't tell you how much a fan i am
this is grown folk music if you did not
know 30 some i ain't rapping by no dumb
[ __ ] hoe keep it real bobby boy he ain't
no kid no mo now keep it real bobby boy
he ain't no kid no mo and if you fill in
how i'm feeling let a [ __ ] know
that sums it up
bobby hall aka logic thank you so much
thank you a beautiful conversation
wow i uh
i kind of forgive you for abandoning me
for that episode
pretty good right yeah that was really
really deep
fascinating guy that absolutely
brilliant fascinating guy besides albums
he's written a book
a memoir and a fiction book and a rock
album
um
his album his new albums at the top of
the charts um
but uh just a fascinating conversation
well let me ask let me ask you this i
mean obviously a lot of that you know
probably hit home for you you've had a
lot of
tragedy in your life you've been very
open about it addiction
you know all of the whole gamut um
and you're you're a creative mind you
you tap into a lot of that for creative
creativity uh what did uh what did you
learn from bobby what has stuck with you
i guess you know
it's so easy to get into uh
and forgive me for saying this because
it's kind of a right-wing talking point
but
uh victim mentality where we feel like
uh we've been so um traumatized and
victimized through our life that we can
kind of live in a victim state but
um
that
no matter how much we've suffered a
little or a lot
we kind of owe it to ourselves into the
world to kind of spin that into gold
and to
you know to take our pain and turn it
into light um
this sounds like i'm reading from a
dozen hallmark cards right now but
it's just true it's just true um
uh
this is a guy who could have wallowed in
his in his pain and his trauma uh it's a
guy who could have been dealing drugs
it's a guy who could have ended up in
prison um and instead he's just brought
a lot of
light to the world a lot of illumination
about his own mental health issues
and um
uh i'm i'm just really impressed it was
very inspiring conversation to me
fascinating well folks uh if you want
more of life's big questions you know
what to do you can just find us on
social media at reza aslan and rayne
wilson and on twitter at metamilkpodcast
and on instagram at metaphysical
milkshake let us know your life's big
question we just might explore them on a
future episode and you can also please
remember to follow rate and review
metaphysical milkshake on apple podcasts
and wherever else you listen to podcasts
if you are reviewing this particular
episode please make sure that you note
that episodes are better when reza is
part of them
uh you can also subscribe to the
metaphysical milkshake youtube channel
and watch our full episodes every week
see you next week when
i will not allow rain to hijack this
podcast for his own personal growth
i insist on being the annoying voice in
his ear
or co-host as whatever however you want
to call it
you're like that little buzzing mosquito
you're like a podcast mosquito
that's my brand but yeah thank you very
much that's the last time i'm gonna do
it i welcome you back into the fold
let's proceed together reza
metaphysical milkshake is executive
produced by rayne wilson reza aslan and
colin thompson
it is produced by safa samazadeh yazd
harris lane mick dimaria hashem self and
dj lubel
cast media is the production and
distribution partner original music by
jeff tang
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
also my therapist is
not bad to look at she's australian so
that makes it easier that's a joke
she's really sweet man and she's you're
suggesting getting a hot therapist
hot therapist that sounds like a really
like like a rap album
a therapist
hey thanks for watching you guys for
more fantastic videos just like the one
that you watch please subscribe to our
youtube channel thank you